loyal supporters in mass and welcome
Edwin with loud applause the Turkish
Prime Minister is on a cross-country
tour his message the broad majority
supports him etowah insists the recent
demonstrations are the work of a handful
of looters and vandals and nothing more
young people that cursed their own Prime
Minister aren't my young people people
who spray graffiti containing curses
aren't people demanding their rights the
situation in Turkey threatens to
deteriorate further protesters in
Istanbul's Taksim Square are demanding
Aaron's resignation they accuse him of
restricting civil liberties and turning
turkey into an authoritarian state this
is how people react when they've been
mistreated I hope our voice will be
heard and things will improve I want to
believe in this I want our message to be
heard half of the Turkish people want
their voices to be heard
Erewhon has downplayed demonstrators
demands for more civil freedoms his
reaction and the violent police
crackdowns have only helped to stoke
tensions in Turkey